olaf scholz will es auf jeden fall
annalena baerbock sagte es ist höchste
zeit und selbst christian lindner ist
seit kurzem fan die ampel parteien
arbeiten gerade an einem großen plan
minderjährige an die ohne runter mit dem
wahlalter einem einer forderung ist dass
wir das wahlalter auf 16 herabsetzen
erstmal mit 16 wählen aber in jeder
partei gibt es bedeutende stimmen die
sagen lasst doch noch mal 16 jahre
runtergehen auf 0 quasi baby wählen
warum das gar nicht so abwegig ist wie
es klingt warum das wahlalter auch
knallharte machtpolitik ist und warum
dieses riesen vorhaben noch eine
riesenenttäuschung werden könnte darüber
sprechen wir jetzt und ich bin schon
sehr gespannt auf eure einschätzungen
und kommentare
was meint ihr gehört der wahlzettel in
kinderhände also
die forderung ist von 1986 übrigens und
immer noch aktuell
olaf scholz will es anpacken seine
regierung will jetzt das wahlalter
senken das ist eine seiner forderung
aber die ist wahnsinnig unpopulär zwei
drittel der deutschen wollen dass
nämlich nicht die wollen nicht dass das
wahlalter gesenkt wird ich bin mal in
unserer zdf archiv ihn abgestiegen und
da gibt es wirklich alles zum beispiel
einen beitrag zur absenkung des
wahlalters von 21 auf 18 und was soll
ich sagen die gleichen argumente die
gleiche ablehnung nur in schwarz weiß
nein das sollte bei 21 jahren bleiben
als vater einer 18 jährigen tochter
halte ich junge menschen von 18 jahren
nicht für reif genug ich bin dagegen
weil die jungen leute sich im
allgemeinen als nicht würdig für das
wahlalter erwiesen haben ich habe dazu
eine persönliche meinung aus eigener
erfahrung die mir gezeigt dass das unter
primaner noch kaum reif sind zu einer
politischen entscheidung zu unreif zu
wenig gefestigt noch nicht mal
strafmündig seien aber schon wählen
wollen das sind heute auch die argumente
wie sie zum beispiel philipp amthor
vorträgt der für die cdu das thema
betreut ich finde es nach wie vor
einfach widersprüchlich dass man den
deutschen bundestag wählen sollen und
gleichzeitig ohne zustimmung der eltern
keine rechtswirksame verträge
abschließen kann das passt doch nicht
zusammen aber vielleicht ja doch es gibt
nämlich drei wirklich gute gründe für
das früher wählen erstens deutschland
wird immer älter das heißt die alten
dominieren an der wahlurne dh die
parteien müssen sich um die besonders
kümmern die jungen sind enorm
unterrepräsentiert dabei bleiben die
ganzen probleme bei denen kleben
klimakrise rancher republik schuldenberg
das baden alles die jungen aus zweitens
sozial benachteiligte jüngere gehen
besonders selten wären noch viel
seltener als sozial benachteiligte
ältere früheres wählen könnte also auch
für die sinnvoll sein damit man die
nicht für immer verliert denn drittens
zeigen studien und hotelrechnungen wer
früh wählt der bleibt doch dabei da wird
früh politisches interesse geweckt ich
bin dagegen weil die jungen leute sich
im allgemeinen als nicht würdig für das
wahlalter erwiesen haben österreich
findet jugendliche sind würdig
österreich ist das einzige land der eu
indem man schon ab 16 wählen darf jetzt
ist österreich gerade vielleicht ein
fragwürdiges beispiel weil die gerade
aus einer regierungskrise kommen aber an
den 16 und 17 jährigen wird das nicht
gelegen haben eine studie der uni wien
zeigt jugendliche können politische
fragen besser beantworten als ältere und
das wissen dazu hat sich noch verstärkt
das fazit der uni allgemein lässt sich
festhalten erstwählerin sind politisch
interessiert kennen sich politisch aus
und weisen somit die notwendige
politische reife an wahlen teilzunehmen
auf jetzt geht es bei der frage nicht
nur darum ob jugendliche reif genug sind
zu wählen es geht einfach auch um
knallharte machtpolitik und das lässt
sich ziemlich genau an zwei balken
ablesen ihr seht mehr junge wähler
bringt vor allem grünen und fdp gerade
einfach mehr stimmen interessantes in
dem zusammenhang vor allem die fdp fdp
chef christian lindner hat das ganze vor
vier jahren noch kategorisch abgelehnt
dann gab es im letzten jahr ein
parteitag die julis die
jugendorganisation der fdp hat ziemlich
dafür getrommelt und jetzt ist wählen ab
16 auch fdp parteilinie also eine
kehrtwende nicht wer das wahlrecht ab 16
fordert sollte sich rechtfertigen
sondern der jugendlichen ein grundrecht
entzieht die cdu das sagt sie immer
wieder will am wahlalter 18 festhalten
mich überzeugt das wahlalter mit 16
nicht bin anderer meinung hinter dieser
anderen meinung steckt aber nicht nur
die sorge dass man mit 16 einfach noch
nicht so weit ist da steckt auch einfach
eigeninteresse dahinter und machtkalkül
die cdu weiß dass ihre wählerschaft
tendenziell älter ist und hat angst dass
die anderen die jungen abgreifen als die
fdp dann kurz vor der wahl sagt sie
möchten in zukunft auch mit 16 wählen
lassen da wird cdu-mann peter altmaier
sauer er twittert ihr seid einfach die
besten wahlhelfer für die grünen die man
sich denken kann drei ausrufezeichen und
danach gab es eine riesen aufschrei das
sei unwürdig dass ein ganz kleines karo
ich finde es ist vielleicht ungeschickt
aber es ist immerhin ehrlich der
vorschlag wählen ab 16 sorgt also schon
für richtig hohem puls und der nächste
denn es recht
[Musik]
was glaubt ihr haben wolfgang thierse
von der spd hermann otto solms von der
fdp und michael kretschmer von der cdu
gemeinsam offensichtlich er hatte nicht
ganz so offensichtlich die sind alle
fürs wählen ab 0 und die argumentieren
mit dem grundgesetz alle staatsgewalt
geht vom volke aus und zum volke gehört
eben auch wer noch in die kita geht sagt
mir wolfgang thierse das ist eine
provokation weiß ich aber wahrscheinlich
eine heilsame weil es auch darum geht da
bin ich schon sehr dafür auch bei den
wahlen so etwas wie
generationengerechtigkeit mehr als
bisher zum zuge kommen zu lassen aber
mal ehrlich wie soll man dann im
krabbelalter in der kabine sein kreuz
machen auch dazu gibt es ein vorschlag
bis man es selber machen kann sollen die
eltern im interesse des kindes die
stimme abgeben das wäre dann das
sogenannte familienwahlrecht und die
idee die hat erstaunlich viele
unterstützer in der vergangenheit haben
sich zum beispiel schon manuela schwesig
renate künast und iren sparen dafür
ausgesprochen auch der ehemalige
bundespräsident roman herzog hat zeit
seines lebens für die idee geworben und
der war immerhin elf jahre
verfassungsrichter zugegeben es gibt da
viele offene fragen werden kinderlose
benachteiligt lässt sich das überhaupt
vereinbaren mit dem prinzip der höchst
persönlichen wahl aber man kann sich
lange darüber streiten so abwegig wie es
klingt es ist längst nicht so eine frage
müssen wir noch klären warum kann denn
dieses riesenprojekt wahlalter ab 16
obwohl es doch alle ampel parteien
wollen noch zu einem riesen reinfall
werden notwendig wäre eine änderung im
grundgesetz und wir so eine änderung im
grundgesetz braucht man im bundestag
keine zwei-drittel-mehrheit die afd ist
strikt dagegen die ampel parteien und
die linke wären dafür jetzt müssten sich
noch mindestens 35 unionsabgeordnete
finden die eben auch mit ja stimmen von
einzelnen hört man das schon aber ob es
wirklich 35 werden eher fraglich das
riesenprojekt könnte also noch zu einem
riesen reinfall werden oder zu einer
riesenüberraschung vielleicht ja doch
übrigens als es mit dem wahlalter damals
von 21 auf 18 ging war erst eine große
mehrheit auch dagegen als dann kam waren
die meisten doch dafür diese
selbstbewusste jugend tanzt und
protestiert nicht nur sie ist bereit
sich mit der gesellschaft schon in
jungen jahren selbstbewusst
auseinanderzusetzen
und was meint ihr wählen ab 16 18
vielleicht ab 0 oder vielleicht wieder
ab 21 schreibt mir die kommentare und
hier findet ihr noch ein sehr
sehenswertes video von den kolleginnen
und kollegen von tera x3 fakten zur
geschichte der demokratie es geht auch
ums wahlalter damit es dann beim
nächsten mal vielleicht nicht wieder
heißt
[Musik]